whether you gather and analyze data or
design Data Solutions
learn how to leverage data gain
real-time insights and design and build
data processing systems with the Google
cloud data analytics learning path this
path was designed to guide you no matter
where you are in your Learning Journey
start at the first stop if you're new to
Google cloud or jump in at a different
stop if you're enhancing an existing
skill set along the way earn skill
Badges and prepare to become Google
Cloud certified
the first few stops will help you learn
the fundamentals of big data and machine
learning data engineering and data
processing with dataflow Google Cloud
offers tracks for data engineers and
analysts choose the track fit for you
and your interests
learn from Google Cloud experts via
instructor-led training or take
advantage of flexibility of on-demand
the choice is completely up to you
Google Cloud offers multiple modalities
so you can learn how you want to whether
on demand or instructor-led you will
gain access to the same course content
in Labs so you won't miss out on a
hands-on experience practice what you've
learned polish your skills and earn
skill badges show the world that you and
your team can leverage data improve
decision making and build data
processing systems on Google Cloud use
skill badges to gain recognition or to
help you land a new role next up it's
time to prepare to become Google Cloud
certified by taking the instructor-led
or on-demand course and checking out the
various guides and Sample exam questions
once you pass the exam you're officially
a certified professional data engineer
on Google Cloud
looking to continue learning or for a
different topic area Google Cloud offers
learning paths spanning across the
solution pillars
from beginner to Advanced this
comprehensive learning path will guide
you along your Google cloud data
analytics Learning Journey time to get
started